[Musique]
depuis le début de la pandémie pour les
experts et les professionnels de la
santé prendre publiquement la parole
comprend son lot de risques l'exemple
récent de la docteur sylvie la fresnaye
à capter notre attention médias traitent
en civis d'expérience affiliés ou su de
sherbrooke dr la fresnaye a récemment
accordé une entrevue pour informer le
public et les parents sur une
inquiétante recrudescence des cas de
bronchiolite chez les nourrissons la
tragédie que nous vivons en ce moment
c'est le petit bébé extrêmement malade
un reportage produit par la station
radio canada en estrie ensuite présenté
les faits saillants de cette entrevue
jusque là tout va bien mais rapidement
ce même reportage a été instrumentalisée
sur les réseaux sociaux par des
opposants mesures sanitaires résultat la
hausse abrupte des cas de bronchiolite a
été faussement associé à la vaccination
contre la copie 19 c'est à ce moment là
que commence le calvaire de docteur
sylvie la fresnaye
docteur la fresnaye bonjour bonjour mais
d'abord merci d'avoir accepté de nous
parler dans un premier temps ce que
j'aimerais savoir fort simplement l'un
c'est qu'est ce qui a fait en sorte que
vous avez accepté de nous livrer ce
témoignage aujourd'hui
c'est que au chu à sherbrooke où
vivaient comme dans le reste du québec
méthode hospitalisation est tout à fait
particulier et on voulait donner un coup
de main ou maman pour que les mamans se
ramasse pas l'obstacle alors voilà ce
pourquoi j'ai donné nous avons décidé
dans le département de donner cette
entrevue là pour aider les mamans à
protéger leur bébé
point
et à partir de ce moment là quel est le
fil des événements comment les choses
ont commencé à dégénérer et comment
votre message a fini par être 10
tortionnaires de façon surprenante
je reçois un message sur messenger me
disant écoutez j'ai vu votre reportage
vous dites que les bébés meurent c'est
la forme d'un paquet d'autres choses est
ce que c'est vraiment un montage
me voilà choqué de dire pardon d'aller
voir ma belle soeur ma pm agnès je
reçois des messages aux messenger me dit
coudonc situe vraiment ce que tu audi
continue ou non tout ce qu'on voulait
nous c'est que les mamans protègent leur
bébé parce que cette année la
bronchiolite était particulièrement
virulente chez les jeunes bébés points
il n'y a personne d'autre gêne au
département nous sommes dix huit médias
les 18 p diable nous n'avions qu'une
seule intention c'est que les mamans
protègent leurs bébés et qu'ils évitent
d'avoir trop de trop de contacts avec
d'autres enfants malades pour éviter que
les bébés et une bronca les fins du
message
et docteur la fresnaye dites-nous
jusqu'où sont allés ses interprétations
erronées de votre message qui était
pourtant simple et clair
ce que j'ai vu c'est trois messages
différents que moi je n'ai pas vu mais
qu'on m'a fait parvenir de gens qui ont
pris des bribes de ce que j'ai dis pas
ce que j'ai appelé c'est une tragédie
parce que c'est vrai qu'on avait
beaucoup trop de petits bébés malades et
ils ont transféré sa 1
c'est la faute du vaccin et c'est la
faute d'un paquet d'affaires jeu ses
projets pour écouter mais ce sont mes
propos avec au dessus une ligne qui dit
voici c nous avons l'explication et
c'est la faute de chez pourquoi nous
inventer c'est pourquoi ils m'ont mis en
lien avec une sage-femme qui dirait que
les bébés morts j'ai rien à voir avec ça
fait rien à voir avec le message de
prendre mes propos
avec des faussetés
pour que les gens puissent soutenir
leurs opinions
ex vous avez une opinion partagée là
mais utilisé pour mon visage et mes
propos et mon université et mon hôpital
pour soutenir vos propos et gay le front
détenir mais passait pas par mon visage
et mes propos pour le faire tenir
est ce que ce genre de choses qui
pourraient vous refroidir à l'avenir
quand vient le moment de s'adresser aux
médias
je m'adresse plus jamais aux médias j'ai
fini
c'est fini je ne ferai plus ça parce que
sur no 18 on nous a demandé qui est prêt
à
donner une entrevue j'ai dit ok regarder
j'en ai donné des entrevues je suis
capable semblera le sable convient mais
c'est fini c'est fini pour savoir que
déjà frauduleux est un jeu 10 et les
propos de radio-canada là ils vont
mettre des faussetés avec le sigle de
radio canada comme quoi elhadj au canada
et l'université et le cius ans dont ces
propos lors qu'ils sont complètement
mensonger hic c'est horrible alex
carignan comme les collègues quand j'ai
entendu qu'ils se retiraient parce que
il y avait trop de 2,2 c'était trop
difficile à suivre au point de vue
publié j'ai compris que pour lui c'était
quand même difficile
meloche comprends je comprends ce qu'il
voulait dire et de tôle à freiner à ce
stade si vous dites qu'il est difficile
pour vous de déterminer les causes
précises de cette résurgence de brûler
donc de cette infection virale chez les
nourrissons mais tout de même il est
clair que ça rien à voir avec la
vaccination ça
ça y est bien bien rien à voir faut
savoir que l'an passé à travers
l'amérique il n'y a pas eu de
bronchiolite
00 cas de bronchiolite
en amérique du nord la partie personne
n'en a vu aux du confinement à cause du
masque parce que tout le monde était
chez eux parce que tout le monde se
protéger parce que personne ne
rencontrer personne n'est ce pas bon non
plus prenant fin de rencontre et
personnes
d'accord mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas vu de
bronchiolite l'an passé ce pourquoi il y
en a plus cette année c'est condé
confignon peu moins de masse qu'on se
lève un peu moins les mains on est
heureux on se voit plus donc plus de
virus
pourquoi les petits bébés ont été plus
atteints je peux pas vous répondre c'est
comme ça et en terminant de la fresnaye
qu'est ce que tout ça vous dit nous dit
sur notre société sur la façon de faire
face à la pandémie et sur le sort
réservé aux faits scientifiques
est ce que notre confiance qui est
brisée ce qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est ce que moi dans ma position
je lis la littérature scientifique
j'écoute nos sociétés savantes ce que je
dis je le lis
de par ma formation universitaire et
scientifique
que monsieur madame tout le monde aille
sur le net et fouilles je réalise
l'ampleur du dégâts faits par les
fraudeurs mais je peux comprendre que
pour monsieur et madame tout le monde ça
doit être
je ne sais pas mon savoir mais je suis
en passant contente que existe quand
même dans ce monde de
déjà qui court après la vérité dont vous
merci infiniment de me permettre de
mettre les pendules à l'heure donc il ya
heureusement quand même la possibilité
de s'en tenir de revenir à une vérité
voilà merci